mein Thema heute ist der Muttertag am
Sonntag gab es ja Blumen und Geschenke
doch nicht mehr über im Land wird der
Muttertag so gerne gesehen ey die
katholische Kindertagesstätte St
Hubertus in ammenue Amöneburg Mardorf
versteht einen Brief an alle Eltern dass
deren Kinder zum Vater und Muttertag
keine Geschenke mehr was denn werden
Beschluss der Teamleitung in dem
Schreiben hieß es dann als Begründung in
der heutigen Zeit in der die Diversität
ja ein immer höheren Stellenwert erhält
möchte man dies nicht mehr vorleben und
auch keinen Menschen ausschließen
deshalb wolle man dieses Jahr auf
stereotype Geschenke wie Blumen für die
Mutter oder Werkzeug für den Vater also
die Geschenke verzichten bei uns hat
sich ein Vater aus NRW gemeldet der eine
ganz skurrile Idee hatte warum man bald
in den Kindergärten dann nicht mehr nur
noch von Erziehungsberechtigter eins
oder beziehungsberechtigt der zwei
spricht so sehr hat ihn dieses
geschenkverbot aufgeregt und die Frage
würde ich gerne hier in Raum stellen
alles wie weit geht das denn jetzt schon
keine Geschenke mehr Kindergärten wird
es bald dazu kommen dass man
Erziehungsberechtigte 1 und
Erziehungsberechtigter zwei sagen muss
naja man darf diese genderei nicht
verharmlosen ja das ist nicht nur der
Spleen von ein paar Leuten die glauben
sie müssten allen ihren ihre Gedanken
aufzwingen sondern die Sprache ist ein
Instrument der Gesellschaftsveränderung
und darum geht es letztlich das normale
soll als das unnormale erscheinen und
das unnormale plötzlich zum zum normalen
und wenn das geht ja dann noch ein Stück
weiter
es wird Pflicht es wird zum Zwang wenn
du das nicht mehr wenn du nicht mehr
genders sind in Firmen in Universitäten
gibt es auch schon ja dann bist du
draußen das ist also die gender das
Gendern ist eine Waffe im Kulturkampf
für viele sogar in einer Kultur
Revolution
und das betrifft die Freiheit von uns
allen deswegen ist heute man das nicht
akzeptieren man sollte sich beschweren
man sollte wenn die in den Nachrichten
Fernsehen anfangen zu Gendern sollte man
beispielsweise bei einer Wege macht also
im öffentlichen rundfunken
hat wenn sich Hunderttausende wenn sich
Millionen beschweren ich war lang genug
beim Fernsehen beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen dann weiß ich das
was passiert ja nur dieses wegducken ja
lass die mal wird schon nicht so schlimm
sein die werden auch mal erwachsen das
ist zu wenig man muss sich zur Wehr
setzen und man sollte auch amtliche
schreiben die geändert werden sollte man
einfach nicht mehr beantworten man
sollte diese Sprache nicht akzeptieren
es gibt doch einen bürgerlichen
Widerstand man kann auch ein gegen
Gendern machen man kann auch darauf
bestehen dass die deutsche Sprache so
wie wir sie gelernt haben und wie sie
üblich ist und sich auch vernünftig ist
das sind dafür vernünftige Sprache
Regeln die sollte man auch verteidigen
Frau Schröder hier wird gesagt er ging
es Gendern Aufstehen sich beschweren
auch ruhig an die talksleitung von Anne
Will schreiben oder da an den ARD ZDF
was sagen sie dazu ja nicht nur das
Gendern wir haben ja im Moment es zu tun
mit einer Sprachpolitik die wirklich ins
vollkommen groteske abgeglitten ist wir
haben das sehe ich an der Universität da
kommt ja der ganze Kram her wir haben
quasi im Wochenrhythmus neue Wörter die
andere Wörter ersetzen weil die
angeblich nicht mehr inklusiv sind weil
sie angeblich einer eine bestimmte
Gruppe diskriminieren letztendlich was
man dabei versucht ist natürlich eine
neue Gesellschaft sozusagen am Reisbrett
zu entwerfen obwohl die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung das ablehnt das Gendern wird
ja von einem großen Teil der Bevölkerung
abgelehnt und obwohl wenn man sagt man
möchte nicht diskriminieren noch genau
Gegenteil in dem Moment wo man sagte es
gibt keine Blumen zum Muttertag mehr und
es gibt den Begriff der Mutter nicht
mehr es ist jetzt die entbindende oder
sowas man diskriminiert und entwertet
Mütter in diesem Fall man entwertet auch
Väter man entwertet auch andere Menschen
die plötzlich nicht mehr vorkommen
bleiben wir einmal ganz kurz bei der
Universität es gab ja auch einen Fall wo
ein Student Punkt Abzug bekommen hatte
weil er nicht gesendet hat der Student
hat dann Einspruch erhoben dieser wurde
aber nicht bewilligt also dieser
Studenten muss seinen Punkt Abzug
hinnehmen passiert das an weiteren
Universitäten ja im Moment ist das noch
nicht so weit aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass weil es in den
Leitbildern ist weil es als allgemeiner
moralischer
Verhaltenskodex jetzt aufgesetzt wird
dass der Druck sich dem zu unterwerfen
immer größer wird und was wir erleben
ist eigentlich nur ein der Anfang von
einer immer rigideren Form der Ideologie
die über alles drüber gestülpt wird über
die Wissenschaft über die Kultur über
die Medien auch zum Teil über die
Politik mit dem Ziel die Gesellschaft in
einer Weise verändern wie sich das eine
sehr kleine Gruppe von Verboten
Ideologen ausgedacht haben
da muss man erstmal das muss man erstmal
entzaubern was da tatsächlich hinter
steht aber eines dieser Mittel nur eines
aber immerhin eines das nun Gott sei
Dank auch auf Widerstand stößt ist eine
neue Sprachregelung
heißt ja immer dass eigentlich das
Gendern vor allem gut für die Frau ist
also vor allem junge Frauen wie du
werden dadurch ja beschützt und gestärkt
weil es ja in der Sprache beginnt ist
das Argument dass man Frauen alles
zutraut und das also eigentlich müsste
ich dich heute Abend hier als Gästin
einladen weil sonst würde ich dafür
sorgen dass du dir auch nicht mehr alles
zutraust nee ich finde eigentlich als
Frau das Gegenteil ist der Fall ich
finde ähm ich werde eigentlich
mittlerweile irgendwie diskriminiert
oder was aufgezwungen was ich nicht will
und die Mehrheit der Frauen will das ja
auch nicht du möchtest nicht gestern
sein heute nee ich möchte ich möchte
nicht geändert werden weil ich möchte
dass meine dass man mich ansieht für das
was ich leiste und nicht weil ich eine
Frau bin und da hebt man ja wieder vor
dass ich eine Frau bin und impliziert
noch so ich könnte es quasi nicht
schaffen gemein zu sein und deswegen
müsste ich noch sprachlich extra genannt
werden dabei werde ich ja sowieso schon
extra sprachlich genannt also ich fühle
mich auch genannt wenn man sagt
Journalistin und ganz normales Plural
wie man Deutsch gelernt hat früher aber
der wesentliche Punkt ist doch
eigentlich wichtig dass wir Frauen durch
deiner Sprache unsichtbar gemacht wurde
ganz am Anfang hat man uns erzählt das
ist eine gleichberechtigte Sprache für
Mann und Frau mittlerweile geht es um
bis zu 72 Geschlechter wenn es nach
manche Personen geht zwischen dem gender
Sternchen und dann gibt es natürlich
auch noch die maskuline und femine Form
ja trotzdem aber das was waren ja damit
im Endeffekt dann als Folge erreicht
wenn man solche auch von Gebärende
Person spricht ist dass wir Frauen
unsichtbar gemacht werden also das Wort
Frau wird ja auch nicht mehr erwähnt und
oder Erziehungsperson eins oder
Erziehungsperson und zwar wir werden als
Frau und dann auch eben als Mutter und
sichtbar gemacht das finde ich dass sie
Folge der Kindersprache ich noch einen
Einsatz das zu sagen was auch noch eine
Effekt ist dass immer weniger Menschen
sich ausdrücken können oder sich trauen
sich auszudrücken weil sie gar nicht
wissen wo sind die aktuellen Fallstrecke
was dürfen wir jetzt alles nicht sagen
das erlebe ich immer seine Meinung
gesagt ja und weil ich sehe ist auch das
Leute sich zum Teil ab
Spülen mit korrekten Sätzen und dann gar
nicht mehr wissen was sie eigentlich
sagen wollten wo ist das denn nicht eher
das Problem der Leute selber also wenn
die sich jetzt abmühen und denken sie
dürfen jetzt nicht mehr
gender Sternchen
Universitäten gibt es noch keinen
Punktabzug da gibt es jetzt Einzelfall
aber man darf immer noch arbeiten
moralischen Druck und Menschen neigt
auch zu Anpassung vor allem zur
Anpassung an die Gruppe in der gerade
ist und dann gibt es diese Verrenkungen
die letztendlich völlig in die Irre
führen weil man den eigentlichen Inhalt
des Satzes gar nicht mehr sagt fragen
wir mal Erika fühlen Sie sich unter
Druck gesetzt
Sprache ich wurde damit noch nie
konfrontiert dabei sie möchten ja
akzeptiert werden weil sie in
Anführungszeichen anders sind sie aber
dann sollen auch die das normale
akzeptieren ich meine es gibt eine Mann
und eine Frau und versteht bei mir
Respekt wenn sie mich respektieren
zu verändern dann spiel mit
seiner Sprache
ich bin noch nie eine konfrontiert
worden also unsere türkischen Kultur
gibt es noch her und Frau also ich bin
wirklich damit noch nie noch nie hat
mich einer geändert oder mit dem da
zusammengebracht oder Bayern
aufgewachsen also in der deutschen
Kultur
aber das ist aber ganz spannende Art das
war ein schönes Schlusswort weil da
merkt man dass wir uns vielleicht
manchmal etwas auch im Blasen befinden
wenn sie sagen bei Ihnen auf dem Dorf
war so ein Thema der Mensch sollte sich
alles gefallen lassen also sowas ganz
klar wie das System sein sondern jeder
Mensch ist individuell und man muss
nicht alles mitmachen was der Vater
startet oder irgendjemand sagt man kann
auch mal seine Meinung sagen es bringt
zwar Probleme wir zwei kennt das aber
man braucht Menschen die reden weil wir
alle die Klappe halten was würde ich
dann verändern gar nicht nur sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie